more time travel Brad Pitt Jeremy Piven
edge of tomorrow's Journey from page to
screen has more twists and turns than
Tom Cruise's time loops
if you're going to try and sell
Hollywood on a potential movie that
isn't rooted in a deeply beloved
franchise you've got to do something
drastic to make sure your idea can stand
out to that end screenwriter Dante
Harper presented the idea of adapting
the novel all you need is kill to Warner
Brothers by presenting them with a
finished spec script rather than just a
generalized pitch for what the movie
could look like this would eventually be
renamed the more marketing friendly Edge
of Tomorrow going this route went
against most protocols for getting new
movies off the ground in Hollywood
writing a finished script for a film
that isn't green lit yet could result in
a lot of work going to waste if the
studio doesn't accept your pitch but
traditional pitches have become so
scarce in the modern Hollywood ecosystem
that Harper and the producers all knew
something more drastic was needed to get
the movie on the radar the result was
that Harper got paid almost 3 million
dollars for his spec script even without
any filmmakers or actors on board much
like edge of tomorrow's protagonist is
constantly turning in the movie
Sometimes risks are well worth it
the primary focus of Doug lyman's
filmography has been big crowd-pleasing
Blockbusters it was a trend established
with his Hit The Bourne Identity with
subsequent directorial efforts like Mr
and Mrs Smith and jumper continuing this
trend he's sometimes helmed smaller
scale Affairs such as the wall or
swingers but he's usually the guy you
call when it's time to direct something
costly that's meant to appeal to a wider
audience so it should be no surprise
that he was called on to direct edge of
tomorrow even if up to that point he had
no extensive experience with sci-fi
storytelling outside of Jumper still
there was more than just a track record
of handling Blockbusters that attracted
Lyman to Edge of Tomorrow the director
revealed that what really attracted him
to the project was the central dynamic
between a super-powered character and
someone who has no abnormal abilities
additionally Lyman gravitated towards
the idea of making that
non-super-powered individual a woman who
could go toe-to-toe with movies male
lead this continued a Fascination Lyman
had Within women that dated back to Mr
and Mrs Smith
leading man Tom Cruise is Central to
Edge of Tomorrow especially as his gift
for comedy really lends itself to the
movie's wacky time Loop scenarios but he
wasn't always the first choice to Anchor
this project back in September 2011 Brad
Pitt was the original pick to play the
protagonist in the movie this would have
reunited Pitt with director Doug Lyman
as the two had collaborated on the Smash
Hit Mr and Mrs Smith it's easy to
imagine why Pitt would have been seen as
a prime candidate to Anchor Edge of
Tomorrow especially since he also has
solid comic chops and would have been a
big enough name to draw moviegoers to
watch an original Blockbuster however he
ended up passing on the part no reason
was given as to why he never took on the
role but it's worth mentioning the pit
was offered this part while he was in
the middle of shooting another big film
World War Z it's not far-fetched to
imagine it being in the middle of one
massive tentpole made him wary of
signing on to another whatever the
reason Pitt turning down Edge of
Tomorrow paved the way for Crews to
tackle one of his most interesting
Blockbuster performances
Doug Lyman has never been a guy who
plays things safely while making his
movies just look at the Bourne Identity
which ended up being beloved but had a
troubled production due to Lyman butting
heads with Warner Brothers it's no
surprise then that lyman's Edge of
Tomorrow had its share of difficulties
getting to the Silver Screen in this
case part of those challenges emanated
from how much of the original screenplay
was tossed just before principal
photography got underway in a past
interview with the Los Angeles Times
Lyman openly admitted that he discarded
around two-thirds of the screenplay
eight weeks before shooting was about to
start the filmmaker was ready to build
an entirely New Vision of this new movie
with screenwriter Christopher McCrory
joining Lyman to crack this concept as
if things weren't treacherous enough
going this route didn't automatically
result in a new complete script in fact
Edge of Tomorrow began filming even
though a complete screenplay didn't
exist at that point despite lyman's
Hands-On approach to getting the story
right the reviews for the film ended up
being generally positive with many
critics specifically praising the
crackerjack script sometimes flying by
the seat of your pants even when it
comes to the screenplay of a costly
Blockbuster can be the right move but
would you please just explain to me what
the hell is happening in the theatrical
cut of Edge of Tomorrow Tom Cruise's
William cage awakens after sacrificing
himself to defeat the aliens known as
mimics as he looks around he realizes
he's been brought back in time to before
the time Loop Mayhem started this means
that Emily Blunt's Rita doesn't know him
but that just opens the door for their
relationship to start anew it's a tidy
conclusion that brings things full
circle while leaving the door open for
the film's central relationship to keep
going well into the future however this
wasn't always the way Edge of Tomorrow
was supposed to end screenwriter
Christopher McCrory explained to film
School rejects that originally there was
going to be an extra Wrinkle in the
film's ending basically you couldn't
kill a mimic alien known as an alpha
doing that would trigger a new time Loop
where the aliens know the plans of the
humans this would lead to a character
killing an alpha during the finale which
leads to the time Loop starting over the
difference in this timeline though is
that the humans are wiped out before
they can execute their scheme Macquarie
had some fondness for this concept but
noted that by the time it arrived in the
movie The Audience would be so
overwhelmed that adding more time travel
tomfoolery just felt like Overkill with
that Edge of Tomorrow went with a softer
more satisfying ending
even once principal photography was
finished on edge of tomorrow it was
still being heavily tweaked and altered
in fact once a batch of pre-planned
reshoots got underway it was announced
that a new actor had been added to the
film's cast Entourage leading man Jeremy
Piven was Now set to be a part of this
sci-fi Blockbuster at the time it was
noted that he would be playing a
character named Colonel Walter marks and
that his participation in the feature
was made possible due to Piven being on
Hiatus from his UK TV show Mr Selfridge
this would have been a massive departure
for Piven from his typical film roles
since he usually plays in smaller scale
comedies rather than massively expensive
Motion Pictures however Heaven never
wound up in the Final Cut of Edge of
Tomorrow no reason has ever been given
as to why Piven ended up on The Cutting
Room floor though it's likely that
thanks to his presence being added in
reshoots he ended up being more
unnecessary than anything else the way
Edge of Tomorrow was constantly evolving
during its lengthy production allowed
Piven to get cast in the film but its
fluid nature also light likely resulted
in him getting axed from the Final Cut
do I look happy the lead characters of
Edge of Tomorrow all must go into battle
against the otherworldly mimics by
strapping on enormous exosuits equipment
that wasn't added on to the characters
in post-production every one of the
actors including leads Tom Cruise and
Emily Blunt had to wear these outfits
which weighed 85 pounds in a breakdown
of the suits with a production designer
on a feature app it was noted that an
extensive amount of thought went into
crafting the finer details of these
outfits including how they needed to be
streamlined enough to just register as
functional rather than cool after all
these EXO suits are made for war not
being sold as toys so they aren't loaded
with extra knickknacks or glossy
qualities once the designs were figured
out for these EXO suits there were still
extensive problems with getting people
in and out of the costumes on set
initially Cruz for example had to spend
a whole half hour just to get suited up
though that time span was soon whittled
down to 30 seconds committing to such
bulky outfits doubtlessly made shooting
Edge of Tomorrow extra difficult but a
dead land an immediate sense of
tactility to this world that you just
wouldn't get if the exosuits were all
digital
throughout Edge of Tomorrow both the
film's protagonist and the audience are
constantly returning to a massive battle
between humans and Alien Invaders on a
beach this expansive set piece was
always meant to be a big commitment on
the part of the cast and crew however
that commitment was originally supposed
to entail just two weeks instead it
ended up going on and on for almost
three months the constant delays stemmed
from Lyman improvising and making new
stuff up as he went along as if that
wasn't enough of a challenge the movie's
big beach scene was filmed on a man-made
location this expansive set took a lot
of effort to keep functioning over a
solitary day let alone multiple months
having to keep this set in working order
not to mention Emily Blunt almost
breaking her nose during all this meant
that filming this battle sequence was a
trying experience unto itself at least
everyone involved can Comfort themselves
knowing that all the Blood Sweat and
Tears did result in an immensely
tangible sci-fi set piece I'm glad we
could uh work this out before its
release add Edge of Tomorrow was greeted
with skepticism over how it would fare
at the box office it wasn't an
unreasonable stance to take given that
tomorrow was the rare non-sequel
Blockbuster debuting in the summer of
2014 a season dominated by new X-Men
Planet of the Apes and Transformer
sequels on its domestic opening weekend
it didn't look like Edge of Tomorrow
would beat out the naysayers with only a
28.8 million dollar debut on a 178
million dollar budget Edge of Tomorrow
needed to have a way bigger opening to
put it on the road to profitability
however on its second domestic weekend
Edge of Tomorrow ended up holding quite
nicely by dipping just 43 percent a much
better than usual hold for a summer
blockbuster from there the film managed
to have a strong weekend to weekend dips
in North America and eventually scored
100.2 million dollars in this territory
and 367 million dollars worldwide while
not a super profitable Venture Edge of
Tomorrow did manage to do better than
expectations thanks to Good Word of
Mouth plus it gave Crews his first star
vehicle outside of the mission
impossible franchise to crack 100
million dollars domestically since War
of the Worlds Warner Brothers
doubtlessly wanted Edge of Tomorrow to
do more in its Global box office run but
there were still plenty to gloat about
regarding how much money this title took
in
not long after Edge of Tomorrow first
touchdown in movie theaters news broke
that a sequel was in the works a few
months after this first reveal
screenwriters were hired to pin a script
for Edge of Tomorrow Too and Doug Lyman
was confirmed to be directing the
prospective project by the time May 2017
rolled around Lyman had confirmed that
this sequel would be called Live Die
Repeat and repeat and that Tom Cruise
and Emily Blunt were excited about the
project with all these positive
developments not to mention enthusiasm
from all the key creative participants
of Edge of Tomorrow it looked like the
sequel was full steam ahead but as the
years went on an edge of tomorrow's
sequel seemed to be slipping further and
further out of grasp Lyman was much more
uncertain on whether or not it would
ever happen by January 2021. blunt
seemed to put the nail in the sequel's
coffin in February 2022 by stating that
a prospective follow-up would be too
expensive to ever go forward even though
it doesn't seem like an edge of tomorrow
2 has been officially axed it's also
looking more and more unlikely that
it'll happen with each passing day
[Music]